نتوقف عند احدى محطات الخدمه في الضفه
الغربيه الفلسطينيه المحتله رجل يرتدي
الزي العسكري يطلب التحقق من بطاقات
هويتنا ليس لديه شاره تعريفيه ولم يخبرنا
من هو لكن لديه بندقيه لذلك نحن مضطرون
وكنا في حيره من امرنا ولسنا
الوحيدين حصلت سي ان ان على هذا الفيديو
من داخل الخليل تم تصويره بعد ايام قليله
من هجوم حماس في سب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكتوبر لم يمتثل الرجل الفلسطيني يقول انه
تعرف على الرجل الذي يحمل السلاح على انه
مستوطن وليس جنديا في هذا المناخ المتوتر
اذا اصدر جندي امرا فعليك الالتزام به
تقبع الضفه الغربيه تحت الاحتلال العسكري
الاسرائيلي ويعتقد ايضا انها موطن لحوالي
ثلاثه ارباع مليون مستوطن مدنيون
اسرائيليون يعيشون في الاراضي المحتله
يعتبر المستوطنون هذا جزءا من وطنهم
التوراتي ويتوسع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
رغم ان مجلس الامن التابع للامم المتحده
يعتبر وجودهم غير
قانوني ومع ذلك فان المستوطنين يشكلون
جزءا لا يتجزا من الخطه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه في الاراضي المحتله كجنود
احتياطيين في قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي وفرق
امن المستوطنات ردا كما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي على التهديدات الامنيه في
المستوطنات والبلدات والقرى وقال
فلسطينيون لشبكه سي ان ان انهم يعتبرون
المستوطنين المسلحين تهديدا اكبر من اي
وقت مضى ان مهمتهم من الجيش الاسرائيلي
تطمس الحدود مع تعدي المستوطنين على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه كما هو الحال هنا في
قريه التواني الفلسطينيه حيث توجد مستوطنه
على قمه
التل في هذا الفيديو ترى رجالا يرتدون
الزي العسكري
يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي بتجهيز فرق من
المستوطنين المدنيين والجنود في المنطقه
وكما ترون هنا يكاد يكون من المستحيل
التمييز بينهم وجهوا بنادقهم نحو السكان
ثم اطلقوا النار بحسب شهود عيان شاركت سي
ان ان الصور التي جمعناها في الضفه
الغربيه مع مسؤول كبير في الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي لم يتمكن من اخبارنا من
هنا يعمل في الجيش الاسرائيلي ومن ليس
كذلك تساءلنا كيف يتوقع من الفلسطينيين
اذا ان يفرقوا وقال المسؤول لشبكه سي ان
ان ان هناك حالات لجنود احتياطيين لم
يتصرفوا وفقا لمعايير الجيش مضيفا انه لا
يوجد مكان في الجيش الاسرائيلي لمثل هذا
السلوك سيتم التحقيق في كل حاله تنتهك
معايير الجيش وقال المسؤول ان الفلسطينيين
يجب ان يتصلوا ب
المحل لكن الناشط الحقوقي الفلسطيني واحد
السكان المحليين باسل عذرا يقول ان
المستوطنين الذين يرتدون الزي العسكري
يجبرون الفلسطينين على ترك
اراضيه
يحى المستوطنون بدعم كبير في حكومه اليمين
المتطرف في اسرائيل اتمار بن غفير وزير
الامن القومي مستوطن وبعد هجوم حماس في 7
اكتوبر خفف بن غفير من القواعد الخاصه
بتصاريح حمل الاسلحه مما يسهل على عشرات
الالاف
من المدنيين الاسرائيليين حمل
السلاح وزير الماليه مستوطن خصص ايضا بعد
الهجوم ما يزيد عن 100 مليون دولار للامن
في الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك اموالا
لتدريب وتجهيز فرق امن
المستوطنين لكن الامر لا يقتصر على
التسليح والتجهيز فحسب لقد شاهدنا بعض
القيود التي فرضها الجيش الاسرائيلي على
الفلسطينيين لا يبعد منزل احتد حتى خم
دقائق من الجانب الاخر من نقطه التفتيش
هذه لكنها لا
تستطيع الاشياء الاخرى قبل ان تغادر الى
المنزل ولكن ليس الكثير منها انها مسيره
طويله تلف عن راس الرجاء الصالح عشان ا
يعني على خمس دقائق بدي الف ساعه منذ
تسعينات القرن العشر شهدت مدينه الخليل
العديد من حالات حظر التجول في يوم
زيارتنا كان هناك حظر التجول من الساعه
السابعه مساء حتى السابعه صباحا يجب على
اعتدال المرور عبر نقطه التفتيش هذه يجب
تفتيش الفلسطينيين بينما لا يتم تفتيش
المستوطنين في العاده يجب على اعتدال
السير على الاقدام بينما يمكن المستوطنين
التحرك
بسياراتهم ويحتاج الفلسطينيون الى اذن
للزوار بينما لا يحتاج المستوطنين الى ذلك
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي ان جميع هذه
الاجراءات تتوافق مع تقييماته الامنيه
توفير الامن لجميع السكان يعيش المستوطنون
والفلسطينيون جنبا الى جنب ولكن القواعد
لكل منهم مختلفه جدا ان هذا المنظر مش
لائق تعيش فايزه وزوجها في هذا المنزل منذ
14 عاما لقد ورثاه من اجداد زوجها يشرف
على منزلهم مركز حراسه تابع للجيش
الاسرائيلي ومع ذلك فهم يخشون على سلامتهم
اثناء مغادرتنا منزل فائزه وقفنا جندي
اسرائيلي يقول انه لا يسمح لنا بالسير على
طول الطريق الرئيسي علينا ان نعود الى
نقطه التفتيش ليتم تفتيشنا مره اخرى لاننا
كنا داخل منزل
فلسطيني
jp over
people لا نستطيع السير الشارع لنا في منل
فلسطين والان نعتر خطرا امنيا لذا نحن
عالقون في نهايه المطاف قام الجندي
بالاتصال برئيسه ليمنحنا اذنا خاصا بالسير
على الطريق الرئيسي شكرا جزيلا خرجنا
وعدنا الى نقطه التفتيش حيث يتم تفتيشنا
مره اخرى لمحه صغيره عما يمر به
الفلسطينيون كل يوم تقول الامم المتحده
انه بعد 7 اكتوبر تم تهجير اكثر من 1000
فلسطين في الضفه الغربيه واجبروا على ترك
منازلهم بسبب القيود الامنيه وعنف
المستوطنين وتفرض الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده الان عقوبات على
المستوطنين المتطرفين لكن الفلسطينيين
يقولون ان ذلك ليس كافيا ليس عندما يتمكن
المستوطنون من اخفاء انفسهم تحت سلطه
الدوله الاسرائيليه نعم ال باغر سي ان ان
الخليل y